So we love name that tune so much
and in a year of so many gatherings, you know,
are not happening obviously we thought it might be fun
to play the current climate,
name that Zoom.
(light applause)
(upbeat music)
I love that.
That is such a good idea.
Okay, here's how it works, we'll show a photo
of a Zoom call and Jane has to guess the reason
for this Zoom gathering.
And if Jane can answer two out of three correctly,
each of our VFFs, hi VFFs,
will get a $100 gift card for eco-friendly,
sustainable bamboo apparel from
Cariloha plus,
(light applause)
I know, by the way, thank you, Cariloha,
we are gonna donate $5,000 to Jane's charity of choice,
which is the Actor's Fund.
(light applause)
I'm so excited to play
but now I feel like there's so much on the line.
I have to do well at this.
I know, okay,
well, you know what?
The higher the stakes, the more of the fun.
All right, that's not even grammar.
All right, here's ready.
That's not grammar either.
Ready? Here's the first, you're such a better,
you're so much better at this.
Okay, maybe you could give me some lessons
on how to like, host.
Ready, here's the first Zoom.
All right, are the people in the zoom
A. In acting class,
B. Doing charades,
C. Having a political argument?
Huh.
I think,
first of all, what an eclectic group of Zoomers together.
(audience laughing)
Yeah.
Very unusual group, but I love it.
It's very diverse.
I am gonna go, because she's doing this,
I believe that might be a book from charades.
So I'm gonna guess charades.
Let's see if she's right.
A book?
Seven letter book.
Or word book, okay.
It was B!
(audience clapping)
Way to go!
Oh, I'm half way there, I can't believe it!
I completely overrode, we were supposed to show
the reveal.
Again, I've botched this job already.
Here's the next one.
All right. Are the people in this Zoom
A. Friends arguing about The Bachelor,
B. In a tutoring session
or C. Breaking up?
Oh.
Okay.
I thought it was gonna be D, that they were analyzing
a Bob Ross painting.
(all laughing)
My favorite!
But,
huh.
I think,
I don't know.
I don't know about you, Drew but I think they look like
Bachelor watchers.
I think they're friends arguing over the Bachelor.
So, A, Let's see.
If she's right.
I can't, I can't do this anymore.
Like, I can't. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, I can't.
Oh my god.
You're gonna break up with me over Zoom?
Seriously?
Uh oh.
(buzzer blaring)
It's a breakup!
So sorry.
All right.
It's two out of three, let's do this!
Okay, here's one more!
(loud clapping)
Okay, in that Zoom, is it
A. A birthday surprise party for a toddler?
B. A toddler trying to call the Tooth Fairy
or C. A toddler in a Zoom time out?
Jane,
name that Zoom.
Oh no! The pressure's too high!
I think, oh lord.
I think it is
were these like, famous on the internet
and I just don't know, am I be slightly punked here?
They're real, actually.
They're all real? Okay.
I think.
Oh, I'm gonna pray that it's,
oh, I'm torn between B or C.
Can y friend, Drew Barrymore help me out?
Oh, like a phone a friend or eliminate one?
Yeah!
Let's eliminate one!
We can't do that graphically!
Alright. I am gonna say
it is a toddler trying to call the Tooth Fairy.
B!
'Cause I think
that would be so cute.
B.
Let's roll the clip.
Surprise!
Oh no!
Happy birthday!
(audience sighing)
That's okay.
(buzzer blaring)
Drew, this is why I wanted,
this is why I wanna be the host
because you have all the answers on the cards
Do you know what?
throughout the entire game.
You know what's fun?
I did it
blind with you as far as,
I didn't know the answers
and I wanted it to be fresh and exciting
and I think reactions are important,
so, I was with you the whole time, not knowing.
(woman laughing)
I'm so sorry.
Never be sorry.
We are definitely still donating $5,000
to your charity and giving $100 gift cards
from Cariloha to the VFFs.
(all applauding)
Oh, thank you, Drew,
you are the sweetest,
thank you.
Jane Krakowski,
I have loved you my whole life
and I would be so honored to ever work,
collaborate, know you, hang out with you,
be in the same room with you, what a dream that would be.
Well, Drew, me too, it would be my honor.
I'm so grateful to have spent the morning with you.
Jane Krakowski
airs Wednesdays, 9:00/8:00 central
on Fox and Dickinson, which you are so incredible in
and as a complete turn
from some of your other performances
and I just love you in that.
I love you and everything.
I have chills everywhere, is streaming on
Apple TV+ right now.
Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you for having me
and thank you for bringing your sunshine
to our lives every morning, Drew, love you.
I'm learning. It's so nice to hang out with you.
(upbeat music)